- I believe this organization
should be putting out
somewhere in the ballpark
of two to 5,000 pieces of content
across seven to 10 channels
on the internet a day
to achieve the business
goals and ambitions
that it has globally.
Yeah!
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
I'm super excited to be here,
it's it's super flattering.
I especially, as somebody who loves
to actually do public speaking,
I've come to realize, you know,
this is so much more
of a fun setting for me
mainly because of interaction
so I'm going to talk a little
bit about a couple things
that I think will bring the most value
to the people in the
room and very honestly,
then I want to get into as
much Q and A as possible.
So, so many of the
things that I believe are
going on and could impact an iconic,
very large scale business like this
is widely available on YouTube or LinkedIn
and so I want to be a little
bit more specific or nuanced.
I think, to set up the framework
because I'm gonna assume
most people don't know me
or where I stand on this,
I believe that the enormous
technology advances
that I'm sure especially a
company like this understands
and then the nuance is
underneath that infrastructure,
I think that the collective in
this room, including myself,
grossly underestimate
what it all actually means
and because it's so big, it's so heavy,
it's so transformative,
if you just think about,
and kind of looking around the room here,
a lot of people gonna be able to do this,
if you truly spent a
half a day with yourself
over, you know, a nice
walk or a bottle of wine
or however you like
decompress and think about
what has happened in technology advances
just in the last 20 years
it gets quite scary.
Obviously you guys do a great
job physically showing that
with mobile devices and the progression
but just the whole nut,
everything I believe in,
and my passion is how communication
basically dictates
everything we do, right.
I was born in this Soviet
Union and so I grew up in a,
I was born in a place of communism
and then I was able to
immigrate to the US,
a place of capitalism and media
and a very different
point of view and I think
in a lot of ways I was very, in hindsight,
taken aback by that or think about that,
I constantly think about why
when there is a coup in a country
do they go to the newspaper and radio
and television station first
before they even go to the palace
and it's because it's the punchline.
The thing that has the
control is communication.
And I think as a matter of fact,
this argument, this debate,
this passion I've had
for the last 15 years
has become much more obvious to people
as the political landscape has changed
across the globe very much on the back
of the modern technology revolution
when it comes to communication.
And for me where I get really
excited as a businessperson
is when I'm met with the
best products or services
that are not necessarily winning the game,
that they're up to completely and utterly
on the back of brand
perception or execution
of communication at this moment.
And so I couldn't imagine for example,
and not knowing everybody's business units
or what you work on,
but every time I go to
a remarkable company
inevitably there's a high
percentage of people in the room
that are working on something
where they are disproportionally
the leader in quality
but the business results are not matching
that product or service completely
and utterly predicated on
either, A, you know, being way too much
of a sales organization
and not a marketing brand organization
or B, not even thinking about
how the actual decision maker
is being affected to make a decision
and where can we reach them
and how and what have you.
And so for me stumbling into
the talent, the natural talent,
that very nice bio, what
I realized from having,
and this might sound very interesting
and it took me a long time to realize it,
the reason I had eight
lemonade stands, and I did,
lemonade stands as a child
which is absurd and very unique is
on a stage like this
actually five years ago
I'm giving the story, I
used to give my bio more,
and I actually remembered
for the first time,
why was I doing that?
Because I was starting to get
a little bit upset with myself,
was I lazy and just one
of my friends to work?
But what I was actually
doing as a six year old kid,
as a six year old child, I was walking,
the 1980s and America was much more safe,
so I was walking about in the neighborhood
and I was looking at the cars driving
and trying to figure out where
to put my lemonade stand sign
on which tree or which post of a sign
and basically 37 years
later right here right now
I'm still doing the same thing.
I've been chasing the
attention of human beings
to figure out where
they're paying attention
and then I spend the rest of my time
trying to make a sign
that's gonna make them stop
and buy my lemonade.
And I very successfully did
that for my father's business
on the back of modern
communication technology advances.
The reason I was able to
build a small wine shop
into a national player in no
time with no venture capital,
nope, not even a credit line,
working with my own small capital,
three million dollar business
doing 10% gross profit.
To build that to 60 million
with no cash infusion
in five years takes one move,
a remarkable ability to make
every penny work like a dollar
in acquiring customers.
How did I do that?
I did that with email
marketing and Google AdWords
because that was the enormous arbitrage
in the market from 1996 to 2001.
An arbitrage and an understanding
of consumer behavior
that my competitive
landscape did not understand.
That has basically become the seed
that allowed me to later
be an early investor
in Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr
because I viewed them as
the next paradigm shifts
and it's what makes me think every night
about voice-activated devices
with AI infrastructure behind them
because every consumer picks
convenience over everything
and will use those
devices to make decisions
and then that becomes the new
toll booth to transactions.
That's very consumer centric,
very much what I think about
when I think about a company like this
is how does that translate
to a B2B environment?
How does that translate to the cliche
things that are at friction to my beliefs
with an engineer sales
DNA driven organization?
And it plays out in
many ways but ultimately
what I think it plays out in is
I genuinely believe for this company
to take full advantage of 49,000 patents,
to take full advantage of
the speed in which it's
deployed to become a leader in 5G
and many other things that
I'm sure people are proud of
or the innovations that are
happening throughout the globe
is A, ironically to become
a media company itself.
And when I say media I mean publishing.
I think over the next decade or two
you will see companies like
yourselves and your competitors
start to realize an editor-in-chief
will sit at the highest
levels in a company like this
because actually being
publishing DNA is imperative.
Which is extremely difficult for a company
because if you're gonna be a publisher
you need to be a publisher,
which is very different
than being an advertiser.
You know, putting out content
that has no direct attribution
to something that you can
measure in the short term
as a funnel to a sales
center to a transaction
takes a level of discipline,
especially if somebody's held accountable
for every 90 days or every year
but that will be the requirement
because a word that has been
really running through my head
quite a bit over the last
couple of years as entitlement.
Mainly because I have
exploded on Instagram
and I get 10,000 direct
messages a week from kids
who are wealthy, affluent,
being totally taken care of
and they hate their parents
for creating entitlement
and they don't know how to get out of it.
But they're making a lot of excuses,
that's a different story.
But what I realize is that
same thing that a 19 year old
whose parents have paid for everything
and she or he is realizing
wait a minute I'm a zoo animal
and I don't know how to live in the wild,
I believe there's a level of entitlement
that is rampant amongst the Fortune 500
or biggest companies in
the world of thinking
that they're entitled to the business.
They make audacious points of view
on their competitive landscape,
they say silly things like,
make razzes and jokes
about emerging competitors
who eventually become their biggest issues
and I've been thinking
quite a bit about that.
And I think it all leads
to actually a very interesting place
which is ultimately both
high net-worth parents
and executives of very big companies
unfortunately are not consumer centric.
Unfortunately play within
their B2B confines.
Score on different metrics
than the actual end user
that they're supposed to be deploying for.
And so my luck, and
that's what I'll call it,
of DNA of only ever being consumer centric
has led to the honor of
sitting here and talking to you
and having people pay attention
and all the nice things
that have happened to me and it's fun
because there's nothing
more entrepreneurial
or rogue or disruptive
than actually caring
about nothing in the middle
but the end consumer.
Pandering to nothing, not
awards, not the press,
not the media, not the B2B environments,
not the conferences not
the people that are fancy,
just the end consumer and
building leverage there
which ultimately gives you leverage
with all the things that I just mentioned
that are in the middle.
And so for me what that all,
all that pontificating
leads to the following,
Ericsson should be putting out
250 pieces of LinkedIn creative a day.
And it probably puts
out three, nine, seven,
and more importantly,
is that picture, video,
and written article white paper?
Is that been contextually post produced
for the understanding of how
LinkedIn algorithm works?
Does it understand that the
adjectives used in the copy
change the difference of
37,000 people seeing it
versus 2.9 million people seeing it?
Is it a video that people
actually want to watch
or was it a video that
somebody wanted to make
because it makes them feel
good of what it looks like?
Does it ladder up to the brand
which is a complete exercise of executives
making subjective calls?
Unfortunately so much
of what big companies do
is an insular game of
politics pandering to reports
that mean nothing and a lot of
other things that ultimately
become the demise of great
companies and it makes sense
but it doesn't have to be that way.
And the place that I
think is most practical
to actually make a hard change
is marketing and communication.
It's very hard to make a
quick change on your product,
it's more difficult to
change your culture,
you know, there's a lot of
things that are a challenge
but not wasting your media money
on television commercials
that nobody watches,
banner ads that nobody clicks
and millions of other
executions that make no sense
other than to the bullshit
reports that sit in the middle
to justify the bad behavior
is something I have an
enormous passion for.
Especially when you have
what I call sawdust.
I'm super fascinated by sawdust.
At some point in our world somebody looked
at people cutting wood and said,
the stuff that's going on the ground
is something I can sell.
and I think about that a lot,
I also, bottled water is the
much more interesting one.
I would probably pay an
uncomfortable amount of money
to have the right to in a
VR setting sit in the room
with whoever she or he was that decided
this was gonna actually play out
selling something that
was free to the world
because as a marketer as you can imagine,
that is a very fascinating execution.
But that's actually how I
view a company like this.
If you think about the sheer amount
of sawdust in the form of unbelievably
compelling tech stories
that happened in the halls globally
around the 100,000 people
that are touching this place
and, you know, one man's
point of view as an outsider,
the sheer underrated
nature of your advances.
The end consumer complete
point of view on this company
that is just not fair to the level of
what you're actually achieving
and even the B2B industry
that is actually doing business with you,
their even own perception
of what's happening here,
yes, comes from cliche, the
DNA of being a Nordic country,
and the way you talk about yourself.
But that is in my opinion
the obvious excuse
to just not being a modern
communications company.
And how you address that
and how you think about
deploying your stories,
your value propositions, your nuances,
across what I believe is
now the real call to arms,
no different than this organization
two years ago taking a
step back and saying okay,
in a difficult European, you
can't just fire everybody,
you know, kind of game,
how are we going to
thread this incredible
business challenge of
updating our talent pool
while becoming pot committed
to something like 5G because
maybe this last chapter
hasn't gone exactly how we wanted
but by winning the next thing we win?
And honestly that is the
most invigorating thing
of technology advances even if
you haven't done the last two
kind of turns as well as you wanted.
If you're the best at the new turn
you just leapfrog everyone, right?
I mean, it's super fascinating.
To me, much like what
you've done operationally
and organizationally and have execute
against some of your core capabilities,
that's kind of how I
think about communication.
It's kind of irrelevant
how well you've done
from 2011 to 2014 in producing creative
for these new environments,
the next decade is gonna
be one enormous game
of volume of output and
whichever biggest companies
in the world figure that
out first and can execute it
will disproportionally
pick up market share.
And what I mean by that for clarity,
was I was probably being kind
on how many pieces of creative
I think Ericsson should be putting out
on just LinkedIn a day.
I genuinely believe what I'm about to say,
as quickly as humanly possible
I believe this organization
should be putting out
somewhere in the ballpark
of two to 5,000 pieces of content
across seven to 10 channels
on the internet a day
to achieve the business
goals and ambitions
that it has globally.
As you can imagine that is
a very difficult DNA shift
in a world where people overanalyze
every single thing on, if
the color is blue enough?
Or let's spend for different meetings
literally debating a single adjective.
Or let me impose my political weight
as the final decision-maker
and just give some feedback
that I actually don't even
know if I really believe
but I need to give it to justify the fact
that I even have a job.
And that is literally how I see it.
And that's not, I'm not
trying to be mean or razz,
that's just an observation and
all of that is the friction
to putting out 5,000
pieces of content a day.
So if I'm right, which I
feel very confident about
because it's already happened,
a lot of what I've become is
not predicting the future,
it's over communicating
what's already happened,
it's just that people aren't
looking or aren't incentivized
to look in the same place as I am looking.
So I think Ericsson needs
to be a competitor to NPR
and have 54 separate podcasts
in the marketplace
globally around the world
putting out a podcast a day.
I think Ericsson needs to
be, today should not be a day
where everyone's so excited
about Mary Meeker's slide deck,
which is amazing and I
am excited for it but
if you just think about the sheer IP
that sits within the for macro
walls of this organization
to put out extraordinary
contemporary decks
in fun ways to consume
across these platforms
to create leverage for
our sales organization
to create revenue, I just think
there's an extraordinary
miss in the B2B environment
and somebody's gonna take advantage of it
and I'd personally like
to be associated with it
for my own long-term
being historically correct
but it's gonna be more fun to
just just see it in the wild
because I think that's where it's going.
So that's what I'm seeing
and I would love to,
I'd love to go into Q and A
and go a little more detailed
with some of that pontificating and so
thank you so much for having me.
(audience applauds)
So am I just gonna hear it here,
repeat it for everybody back
home and the cameras, great.
Who's got a question?
Yes.
Oh we do have a mic, awesome,
yes, yes, great, thank you.
- [Audience Member] You mentioned 5,000
pieces of content on LinkedIn.
I'm the one who posts
the content on LinkedIn,
one post or two posts a day.
How do we communicate and
get everyone in the company
that understands to amp
up the social media team?
We have a few people, like
maybe a handful of people
and we're already stretched to our limit
for what we wanna do.
We wanna do these things,
we just, the time.
How do we be able to sell that in
to everyone else in a good way?
- Sell that in because you're asking them
to help you produce
content or sell them in
because you want them to amplify it
or sell them in because you want
allocation of more resources to hire?
- [Audience Member] More resources,
less demand on doing other things
which is like producing press releases
and putting press releases out.
- So a macro media thing.
How do you do that?
You do that in most organizations
by communicating in a way
that may lead to you getting fired.
(audience laughs)
I think the reason I answered it that way
is it's actually the truth.
If the people that are actual
practitioners of any craft
are not willing to be aggressive
with their convictions
to communicate to CFOs
nothing will ever happen.
There's only two ways I've ever seen
big companies do the right thing.
One, a cheerleader who
mounted enough political clout
to actually get something done.
Or two, massive pain at the macro level
that has required them to
take a deep look at themselves
and change their behavior, that's it,
that's it, that's it, you know.
You know, you're gonna have to find
who can help you get it done.
To me the ability, or the
internal and external partners
that create this ability
to communicate is oxygen.
For me, the amount of things
that I would be willing to give up
at this company if I was the CEO
in return for the ability to put out
5,000 pieces across all platforms,
being 500 on LinkedIn a
day is almost everything
except the core innovation.
Definitely the bananas in the hallway.
I mean that and I mean it for a purpose
because as my profile has grown,
as my results have spoken,
as many things have happened, you know,
I come from being a businessman,
I'm not necessarily a
comms person by trade.
I'm quite proud that every day
since I've been a professional
I've been the CEO of a company
that has grown exponentially,
every day, every single
day that I've breathed
from 22 to 43 I've been at
the helm as the CEO and COO
the way I operate of two
companies that have been
the fastest growing
companies in their sector.
I'm proud of that.
What that also allows me to do
is as the last half decade
of my career is evolved
I'm now sitting down with board members,
CEOs, CFOs, activists, investors,
and when I look at a true P and L
my ability to have a logical, financial,
or operational conversation
around the notion of
you're telling me of no
more money to pour in.
First, 90 cents of the dollar
that you're spending
on marketing and media
is going in the garbage.
You have no money for social media
but this company is thrilled
to buy a booth at a bullshit conference
that costs more than the entire budget
of your Linkedin media spent.
Let's just, one more time, I
don't even know your P and L
and I know I'm right right now.
I know because I know because
it's a pattern recognition.
I know that this company
will spend more money
building out a booth at some conference
that mattered 21 years ago
then they will spend on
working media dollars
properly deployed on LinkedIn
which is the global communications portal
of the B2B world, the end.
Like what what else needs to be said?
(audience applauds)
In a world where I used
to think I was smart
but the clapping and
reactions in this room
overtime taught me I wasn't smart,
I was just in a position
where I could tell the truth.
My question to this
reaction is, so why, what?
Like how do we fix that?
Who is your external media agency partner
who isn't incentivized
to deploy the dollars
in your best interests,
they're deploying it
in their best interests
because they're inevitably
a holding company themselves
that's publicly traded and
they're pushing television
and programmatic media spend
because that's where the
margin is, that's the truth.
Who's gonna fix that?
Obviously I heard earlier
today you have a new CMO
and, you know, it's her, it's
the CFO, it's the legacy.
Inevitably in companies like this
sometimes even at the
family level or the CO
level there's a
relationship with an agency
that's 21 years which inevitably means
you're getting ripped the fuck off.
So, you know, these are the
things I'm thinking about.
- [Moderator] If you could
just also repeat the question.
- Yeah, so I'm so sorry, that question is,
there's two people
posting, how do we fix it?
(audience laughs)
- I have two questions.
- Two questions.
- [Audience Member]
The first one, you said
2,000 on LinkedIn, try to
post on social channels,
how do you come up with those figures?
And then the second question is,
can you tell us a time that you failed
and what you learned from that?
- Great, the question is,
how do you actually practically deliver
on these two, three, four,
5,000 pieces of content a day, a week,
how does that actually get done?
And the second question is
talking about a time I failed,
and third, please?
- [Audience Member] How
did you come up with 5,000?
- Completely out of my butt.
(audience laughs)
And let me explain what I mean by that.
I'd actually like it to be more,
I just don't think you can get there.
And I think about what my intuition is
on how much money you're
wasting on marketing
and if that was deployed
on the ambition of making
a lot of content that you would get to
those kind of numbers, got it.
So whether, listen, I
would dance if you put out
15 meaningful pieces of
LinkedIn content a day, right?
You know, I would dance.
And meaningful, and what I mean by that is
I have so much empathy for internal teams
trying to do it with press
releases, everything.
You have to understand,
if I was sitting and having
dinner with my mom right now
and she said, "hey, son
really, like really,
"what's the punchline of
why VaynerMedia and you
"are so right, like,
what has been going on?"
I would say mom, "it's our
post-production capabilities
"for the content, context, and nuances
"of the seven platforms
that have all the attention
"with an overlay of deep empathy
"for the person that's consuming it."
Like, the one craft that I've developed
and now have scaled
internally is just human IP
of understanding math and
art, quant and qual around,
you know, it's funny,
when you look back at
how I'm talking here,
it's value post production
contextual creative,
it's not posting on LinkedIn
for the sake of posting.
You know, the ROI of any execution
is predicated in your skill set.
And so I arrived at the number based on
eventually at scale, AI machine
learning, all these things,
we'll be able to create so much
micro fragmentation of
a lot of these things
and hopefully you know
create content at scale.
But for the time being what
does, you know, I for example,
I have a 30 person full-time team
that works on my personal
content as one person.
I did put out 15 pieces of meaningful
post produced creative for
LinkedIn yesterday, me.
You can imagine if I'm able to do that
what I think you should be able to do.
Me versus Erickson.
So as far as failing, it's interesting,
I don't have like a
fantastic obvious failure
and that's actually a weakness
because it's very grounded
in my deep, deep, deep immigrant roots.
I've never done anything that
is so overextended myself
that if it didn't work
that I would really fail.
Where I've really failed
is on the things that I haven't done.
I've fantastically passed on
Uber twice in the angel round
and that $25,000 check would
have made me $500 million.
I fantastically didn't even reply
to Air Bed and Breakfast's email to have,
which is what bnb stands for,
to invest in their company.
I've passed on a lot of opportunities
that have become fantastic,
they're the most obvious.
And then the really
biggest mistakes I've made
is when I didn't come to a
conference like Brilliant Minds
over the last five or six years
and that would've been the conference
when I met someone and she and
I would have done something.
So it's much more when you're
crippled by opportunity
it's the hidden things
that you've passed on
that are the great
mistakes of your career,
especially when you're like me
who's not ever playing a
financial arbitrage machine game
where you're trying to
slide one past the goalie
and hope your timings right.
I'm a marathon runner
in a sprinters costume
and so I don't put myself in a position
to be that vulnerable.
The other thing is, from from 18 to 29
I worked every single day, all of them.
And so I definitely think
like one vacation a year
for a week with my friends
from high school college
would have been a good idea.
I was just so passionate, I so
wanted to pay my parents back
for being the greatest parents
and bringing me to America
that I was obsessed with
building that family business
and I probably could have
had a little bit more leisure
in my 20s which I regret.
Not really, but yes, you know what I mean?
Not really not because I
became successful, honestly,
because I just loved it.
I go garage sailing on the weekends,
literally go to people's yards
and try to buy things for a
dollar that they're selling
that was in their basement
and then repost it on eBay
for eight dollars and
in that seven dollar ROI
get more excited than landing
an eight million dollar client.
So for me businesses my
hobby, you know, and so,
that's why I say, not really,
because I just loved it.
I loved you know working
the register on a Saturday
when I was 25 years
old because I loved it.
- [Audience Member] Hi,
I have a question here.
So when you talked about the volume
and take it up to 5,000 posts a day,
but you also talked about the
importance of being relevant
and having meaningful content.
How do you ensure that you stay
relevant to your followers?
- The question is, in an ambition
of thousands of pieces of content a day
how do I also nail home relevance?
Which is a big part of it.
So ironically this volume framework
inevitably creates relevance.
What will happen, it's kind
of like a workout plan.
If I'm able to get my partners, friends,
people I care about, clients, my own stuff
into a framework of volume inevitably,
let's just say somebody was
in here and said, "approved."
And everyone's like, okay now we do it.
Inevitably tomorrow's board meeting is,
well what are we gonna say?
And what you realize is,
and this is devastating,
like one of the things that's
been really fascinating
and we work with very large companies,
is once you see it you can't unsee it.
And and the level of
visceral negative energy
I have towards the
modern-day marketing world,
watching some of my clients
starting the process of going there,
it's real fun for me because
literally a week earlier
they're having this subjective
completely non practical meeting
and then a month later after
the first month of this work
they can't even stay in
the room for 10 minutes
because it seems so silly.
It's like many things in life,
once you see something
sometimes you can't unsee it.
So the entire model is built on relevance.
All of a sudden you are
making a piece of content
to female CIOs in Russia.
Because you're making
5,000 pieces of content.
Like, you're not gonna
make vanilla anymore.
You're in the business of
selling vanilla, you are.
Everything is so over corporatized
and everything's trying
to reach everybody,
even when the seed of
the idea was a good idea
by the time it sees the
day of life it's vanilla.
When you've made the
commitment to producing volume
everything is relevant because
you start becoming educated
on how deeply powerful these platforms are
and if I want to reach
a CTO that went to MIT
and I want to use MIT
colors in the creative
because I know that makes her or him
more likely to click it, I
mean this is real stuff now,
all of a sudden 5,000, you
can't imagine how quickly
through a detailed
conversation around this
5,000 seems way too little.
Everything, like just think about
the two examples I gave you
and how your minds running
with the fact that this
is actually in perpetuity.
Every school, every
neighborhood, every geographic,
every job title, every organization.
Like that's just the framework
of seven or eight cohort
beginnings that is an X and Y
which allows you to go forever.
You could be making
content that starts with,
hey are you 28 years old?
And the person who sees it is, yeah I am.
You know, like you can't imagine
how infinite this actually plays out
and so, you know, it was fun
to hear you ask the question
'cause I was smiling inside, I'm like,
it's once you make the
commitment to that framework
the only thing you can do is relevance.
And by the way, relevance is
the only thing that sells.
Not potential reach which is
the currency of big companies.
GRPs and impressions and the
cost of those impressions
potential reach, not actual reach,
it's being reported as
you reach those people.
You don't believe that, you
don't believe that article
reached 29 million people.
Potential reach versus
actualized relevant consumption.
That is the delta.
- Hello.
- Hey, sir.
- [Audience Member] It's very fascinating
talking about the volume so
I'm staying on that as well.
We have this target group of 500 operators
and key decision-makers in each operator
and when we do less content with them,
sort of more focused on
keynotes, stuff they are in on.
Whenever we start going into volume
and work a little bit further
from our core operators
and makes it a bit more
about general technology.
It's interesting that
our volume has gone up
but it's also draws more students,
sort of tech interested
people in general, so yeah,
but I do think that we're sort of
flooding the channel a little bit
for some of those core decision makers
so we've definitely
become much more famous
and pulling in more and more people
but I think that a lot of these executives
that actually buy our stuff, you know,
get our messages with them can sort of
get a little flooded a little bit.
- So don't don't let them see it.
The question is, we're flooding
the 500 decision-makers
who actually drive our business
if we go to this model.
Yes we build the macro brand
and there's more interest
but we're actually over
communicating to the decision maker
which makes them tune us out
which could be detrimental
to our business.
Don't let them see it.
See, the thing that's most fun
about being an actual
practitioner of your craft,
which I'm sure all of you feel the same.
You know, it's funny over
the last five to seven years
I'm like, wait a minute,
I really understand this,
I really understand wine,
and I really understand the New York Jets.
What I don't understand is everything else
so I've started becoming a very
not interesting dinner guest
because I don't even
have excitement anymore
to talk about things that
I'm a headline reader of
or kind of know.
You could black out the 500 people
that you're scared of bothering
when you're posting that content.
You're also making assumptions
that they see everything.
There's so many variables
that go into this.
Plus, we haven't had the conversation
of what you should be surrounding,
you know what's great about B2B?
You know who you're selling to.
You know, a lot of my
B2B friends get mad at me
but I've done very well in
exiting my SAS businesses,
I have a B2B business now, I
used to have a B2C business.
B2B is easier than B2C.
I just don't know what else to
say, one man's point of view,
I just like the idea of
knowing who the 500 people are
that I need to do business with.
Let's go into a slight
variation of my model
in what you and I are discussing.
A, on our LinkedIn
channel let's start there,
our ability to not let
them see it is very high.
You just black them out from those posts,
so that's mission one.
Biggest issue that we were talking about
in the short term accomplished.
But let's go on offense
instead of defense.
What about the fact that we can know
that those 500 people in today's world
based on how many people are sharing
or if we want to just take
the admin of that person
out for a drink if they're into fishing,
if they're into proper football,
if they're into many other things,
and then we can feed them that.
I literally closed the
four million dollar account
by talking to that person about
St. Louis Cardinals baseball
because I saw that that's
what he was Tweeting about.
The reason we take them on
fishing trips and golf trips
and all the stuff that we wine and dine on
we could be doing in relevant content
for a hundredth of the price
so that's my answer to
that question, right,
we don't have to flood them
because that's what's good
about modern technology,
you can control the levers.
More importantly I'd like to flood them
with more things that all individual five,
we should have five people in creative.
You know, in a world where you're like,
we have a small team and
we have to do everything
and dumb shit like press
releases, I'm saying,
let's create eight person production
and strategy and media
teams per 500 people.
I would build a 4,000 person team
to produce content for 500 people
because it would be ROI positive.
To your point, they're
driving our business
so let's become the greatest executor
of what they want to consume
and brings them value.
The problem is, not knowing
what you're putting out,
the problem is is that oftentimes
we're not putting out content
that is valuable to the person
on the other side in the macro.
We're talking about our
products and services.
Ericsson has permission
to talk about everything.
And what Ericsson needs
to do is make a graph
of what are the other 90 things
that these 500 people care about
that have nothing to do with us
and let's be the greatest publisher
of information around that.
Not to mention, the ability
to use these channels
to create content that pulls those people
into real life is remarkable.
I use digital as a gateway drug
to interpersonal relationships.
So if we know that 13 of them
are the biggest wine connoisseurs
and we decide to get Jancis Robinson
and fly her in here and do a wine night
and then send an invitation on LinkedIn
that is gated that, are you interested
in a 1961 Bordeaux tasting
hosted by Jancis Robinson
on a pretty boat on a beautiful summer
day here in in xyz city, tends to work.
We're just not committed to the craft
'cause we are used to a top-down
culture of communications.
Make a single blunt object at the top,
force it down every
channel with no context.
- Hey, Gary.
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm Jos.
- Jos.
- [Audience Member] I just
joined Ericsson a month ago.
- Awesome, yep, I heard, yes.
- Thank you for being here.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] It feels
like a lot of the world
that we've been living in for 11 years
to communicate to Ericsson so I'm thankful
for having these conversations
and bringing the human aspect
to the scale of Ericsson
of being human when
anyone asks me what we do
and having the conversation with you
was one of the interesting
parts of the conversation
that we've been having.
So I wanted to ask you a question on this
which is more of the
what you actually talk about in channels
to be relative and be relevant to people.
Lots of us struggle
with this, working hard,
which is sort of the
stickiness of your content.
But you also talk a bit more
about the death of this,
of working hard but also being sustainable
and taking care of yourself,
can you talk a little bit about that?
- Sure, the question is,
thank you for knowing
a little bit about kind of my trajectory
of how I've been filling the pipes.
What I've been to your point
and thank you for knowing that.
Definitely when I transitioned from wine
to let's say entrepreneurship
in my content
it was 2007, eight, nine,
and we were going through
a global economic crisis
and as you can imagine as an immigrant
who answered your question
of what my regret is,
I don't I think it's very
difficult to give advice that says
become more talented.
Be born with more talent,
very not practical.
So where I found myself
was going to another place
that felt very practical to
me and as you can imagine
it's all I ever saw for the
first 35 years of my life
which was work ethic was a
controllable part of the game
that if you did that if you're
out working your competition,
practicing after practice,
all the things we know about
sports and music and theater
and acting and all those things,
that that was an incredible advantage.
And in a time and place where
people were getting laid off
and things of that nature
it hit the right tone.
It was natural to me and
the timing was right.
To the more nuanced
question which I appreciate
which means you're paying attention,
over the last 18 to 24
months as the world changes
as we get into entitlement
era after 15 years of economic
or 10 years of great
global economic growth,
much like my concern with entrepreneurship
because there's so much
money in the system
everybody's idea gets funded
and we're not building businesses,
we're just building companies
to get more funding.
What has also happened is
a more human conversation
more Nordic and European centric
than US and China centric
about work-life balance,
about mental health issues, about burnout.
I found myself two years ago
watching contemporaries, even friends,
start to use me as a poster child of bad.
That I was pushing too much burnout
and things of that nature,
hustle porn and other things,
and I was empathetic to it.
As much as I was hurt and
wanted to make 500 videos
of in the first book, which is my Bible,
I talk about if you want
to work nine to five
and make 40,000 a year but
if you're happy you've won,
I think I've been and I have been
incredibly consistent
around happiness, not money
and many other things but to your point,
because of my personality traits
what was associated was
hustle and things that nature
so I have to take responsibility for that
and so over the last 24 months
I have spent more time and energy
to contextualize everything
to make sure I'm covering the bases
so that people know where I stand on this
which is what I said earlier,
I don't actually regret it
because I loved, business is my hobby.
But if one wants to go
to every softball game
or every track meet or, you
know work, 31 hours a week
and they're fulfilled that makes me happy,
I don't get to judge.
So yes I think what's so
great about communication
and so great about advancements
is you can create clarity,
you can talk about different things,
I talk a lot more about parenting today
than I did in the past because,
not even because I'm a parent,
because I've been more in
tune to how I was parented.
So yes, I've definitely
been more aggressive
in making sure the things
that I've always believed
are more associated with me
because I have no interest in other people
painting a picture about
me that isn't true.
But it all goes to one big
game of self-awareness.
You know, you can get burned
out work in 30 hours a week
because you're unhappy
because you're trying to be to work life
but what actually you
are is an alpha go-getter
and you do want to grind.
Not living your actual
life is the problem,
letting other people's opinions
dictate your behavior is the problem.
Self-confidence, most
parents create insecurities.
Hi.
- Oh, I have the mic.
- That works out, whoever has the mic
gets to ask the question.
- [Audience Member] I'm
curious about the question
that the others asked
before we talked about it,
so how are you gonna
make those 5,000 posts?
- First of all, thank you,
the question is how do you
practically make 5,000?
So a couple things, one, as I became more
in tune to this model
over the last three years,
which is the evolution of
everything I've been doing,
it's really interesting,
Twitter has become
a far more important platform for me
and Linkedin has become a
far more powerful platform
because 5,000 when you hear
that seems super daunting
if you're close enough to the business
where Ericsson does the cliche thing
which it spends $500,000 making a video
because their creative
agency wanted to make it
and nobody's ever gonna
see it and it cost 500,000
because you starred somebody
in it and it's just 500,000.
and so you hear that and you're like,
this is crazy, we can't make 5,000.
It took us four and a half
months to make that one video.
When you think about
the world the way I do
which is you have so much internal IP
that putting out 50 Tweets in the morning
in written form with no picture
or video support behind it
but they are just thoughtful questions,
statements, observations, hot
takes as I like to call them,
whatever it may be, when you do that
all of a sudden you start
seeing how the number can go up
but where it gets most
interesting is why do you do that?
Why should Erickson from 9:00
a.m. to 11:00 a.m. put out,
you know, 84 between LinkedIn and Twitter
because that's a place
where you can get away
with the volume in the
feed without overexposure
but can still get actual consumption
because if it doesn't do well
it doesn't penalize you in the same way,
the way an Instagram or Facebook does.
This goes into
understanding the platforms,
why should LinkedIn, excuse me,
Ericsson put out 84 pieces
of content in written form
on LinkedIn and Twitter from 9:00 a.m.
to 11:00 a.m. every morning?
It's because what happens from 11:00 a.m.
to 4:00 in the afternoon next.
What is amazing about the volume model
is the notion of marketing for
the sake of better marketing.
So what happens after you post those 78
is you start getting
quant and qual feedback.
And what you do with that feedback
is you make the next decision which is
are you going to write more about that
or has there been such a huge reaction
to people's response on
what 5G actually means
to their day to day, not just
faster and better battery,
but how our entire world changes
when you create that speed of information,
how that actually makes
autonomous cars real,
how that actually allows a doctor in Peru
to perform a surgery on
somebody in New York,
how that actually actually actually does.
When you see the response
now all of a sudden you say,
you know what, that little
three sentences we said about,
did you know when 5G is
in your life this happens,
got such a big response,
why don't we now have
our graphic designer make
an infographic real quick
around five things you don't know about 5G
and let's post that at 3:37 p.m. today
and then when that goes
well then you decide,
why don't we go quick
little video on our iPhone
talking to Lars in R and D he
knows a lot about this shit.
Let's go over to him, Lars says it,
and then you just post it not with
what's quality with
green-screen and lighting.
I mean, I was powdered before
I came out here right now.
(audience laughs)
That to me is not the variable
of success of this talk.
That was not going to be the variable
that made this go well or not.
It was what I was gonna
say and Lars with an iPhone
with bad lighting saying
something thoughtful
and then that posted at
7:04 p.m. on our Twitter
to the small group that cares matters
and so when you get into that mindset
you can see how it works
and its really just
having writers, designers,
something we call predators, shredators,
which are people who can film
and post produce for the
channel all in one person.
Talent, humans.
Commitment to being able to pay
those people to do the thing
because you value that more than
the lighting in your booth
in Spain at a conference.
(audience laughs)
I went there.
It's always fun to go somewhere
where the group knows
exactly where you're going.
And I'll tell you why I go there,
I go there because you're
going there to check a box
of what's normally gonna happen anyway.
Your your most senior
executives are having dinners
with those clients to begin with anyway,
you're just you're just
spending a lot of money
on something that
actually matters far less.
I don't mind checking a box
for perception is reality, I don't.
I mind that what I actually said,
which is the lighting of
that booth or that pavilion
costs more than all the
media dollars you deploy
against targeted LinkedIn
creative, that's what I mind.
Doesn't mean you're not spending
a ton of money on media,
it's just that your media partner
is incentivized to spend
that media in a way
that's in their vested
interests, not yours.
This is the conversation,
this is real life,
I like real life, thank you.
(audience applauds)